pride
greed wrath
envy lust gluttony
and sloth the seven capital vices
or seven deadly sins
succumb to any of these sins and you may
find yourself in your very own version
of the divine comedy
being guided through hell and having the
displeasure of climbing out through
satan's nut sack
or maybe not who knows
i'm no expert it's likely you've heard
of the seven deadly sins in some
capacity
when we discussed peter binsfeld's
classification of demons
each one of the seven princes of hell
represented
one of the seven deadly sins this became
a fairly common way for historians and
demonologists to personify
and create a taboo around these ideas
today we'll take a look at what these
sins actually
meant and why they were so deadly
[Music]
before we proceed any further i must
tell you about the undiscovered deadly
sin i came across when researching this
video
the passage says he or she who does not
know of this plate
will bear the curse of never knowing the
wonders of beautiful magnet mounted
metal canvases luckily this isn't
something we have to concern ourselves
with
because today's video is sponsored by
diss plate
a disc plate is a metal poster or canvas
that
makes for a great display piece with
over 1.4 million
artists and partnerships with huge
brands such as marvel
dc and star wars i'm sure you'll be able
to find something that suits your taste
as you can see the awesome people over
at display have sent me some designs i
requested
we have everyone's favorite italian
plumber looking creepy as ever
a vibrant space piece and of course
lovecraft and cthulhu looking
almost as creepy as our plumber when
these arrived i thought i was gonna have
to start drilling holes and
making a mess everywhere but mounting
these canvases
is as simple as sticking a pair of
magnets to your wall
which then secure your canvas in place
not only is it extremely easy to mount
your disc plate
but if you decide you want a new design
you can simply pull it straight off the
magnets
and attach a new one in its place if
you'd like to browse the rest of
display's collection
you can save up to 37 percent of your
order by using the link in the
description
although the seven deadly sins are
largely a christian concept
we do have similar ideas from the
ancient greeks and romans as well as
many other religions across the world
it's common for the seven deadly sins to
be paired with the seven
holy virtues because they are examples
of how we should
and should not behave aristotle saw this
as less of a concrete
right and wrong system and more as a
spectrum of behavior
if one veers too far off in any
direction
we move into vice territory if one
manages to stay in the middle of these
extremes
you'll be showing positive qualities and
virtues
one example would be fear if you are
scared of
everything then you will miss out on
things in life
because you allowed fear to control you
an example of cowardice
the quality of virtue that conquers fear
and cowardice
is courage however if one shows too much
courage
we now lean heavily over to the other
side of the spectrum
which is recklessness too much courage
may leave you in situations that could
have been
easily avoided rather than the approach
of this behavior can only be good
or bad this is much more of a balancing
act
trying to maintain a healthy mean as
opposed to the idea of sin
and virtue anyway moving on to the
christian
or more accurately the catholic concept
of the seven deadly sins
the most concise definition i've come
across is as
immoral behavior that would separate one
from god
and in turn lead to more sin being
committed
a venial sin would weaken one's
relationship with god
but not completely sever the bond as the
deadly sins would
turning your back on god was thought to
make one more likely to commit
what are known as mortal sins if you
then die without repenting for these
mortal sins
you go straight to hell so the seven
deadly sins are essentially the gateway
or temptation that leads to more sin
these ideas are first discussed in the
catholic church by pope gregory the
first he wrote about the seven deadly
sins in the sixth century
a very similar idea was discussed
several centuries before
by the monk ivagrius who instead listed
eight evil thoughts these thoughts were
translated from greek to latin by john
cassian
pope gregory then streamlined this
number to seven sins in his text moralia
and thus we have the seven deadly sins
gregory's list was then used again in
the 13th century by thomas aquinas
who further expanded upon the ideas
behind these sins
the first sin is pride which is also
commonly referred to
as the father of all sin pride however
in this case refers to
ego or the idea of hubris which is
prevalent in greek and roman myth as one
of the worst crimes one could commit
whenever someone believed they were
equal or
greater than the gods they were swiftly
punished and made an example of
once one succumbs to pride this
symbolizes a lack of humility
the welfare of others is ignored in
place of their own
urges and desires this selfishness only
leads to contempt
and other sin the most classic example
we have of pride is
lucifer the most beautiful of god's
angels
lucifer began to question everything
about the universe he had been told
eventually he started to believe he
could do a better job ruling heaven than
god himself
this led to a great war in heaven that
lucifer would
ultimately lose for his rebellion he was
cast from heaven
and forever known as the fallen angel
who would embody the
sin of pride the opposite of pride
is the virtue of humility or humbleness
the next sin is gluttony this is the act
of overindulgence to the point of waste
although gluttony is most commonly
associated with the consumption of
food it can also refer to an
over-indulgent lifestyle
not too dissimilar from greed there are
several different types of gluttony
thomas aquinas divided gluttony into
several forms
eating food that was too expensive
luxurious
or exotic eating food in excessive
quantities
eating food that required elaborate
preparation
eating food at an inappropriate time
and lastly eating food too eagerly
the virtue of gluttony is temperance or
moderation
exercising restraint and modesty are
examples of how not to succumb to
gluttony
moving on to greed or avarice as it's
also known
this sin focuses on desire the
uncontrollable desire for material
social and political gain from this
stems all sorts of questionable behavior
hoarding riches and materials that could
be used to help those in need
stealing in order to obtain what you
desire or lies
trickery and the manipulation of others
in order to achieve
status or political power early european
theologists would go as far to say
other than the devil there is no greater
enemy to man
than the desire for money this was
commonly used when discussing usury
which is the practice of making
unethical loans which exceed the legal
interest rates
often taking advantage of others
misfortunes
this is what we would refer to today as
a loan shark
similar to pride the greed is considered
a gateway into numerous
other sins as well as the root of many
evils
lust is the capital sin that relates to
desire of a
sexual nature this was seen as leading
to
fornication adultery sexual assault
seduction and bestiality in some odd
cases
most religions will distinguish lust
from passion
lust was considered an immoral desire
whereas
passion was more widely accepted as god
given
and the main driving force behind
reproduction
lust does also come in some other forms
such as the
unbridled desire for money power and
even food
these are minor forms of lust that
relate to gluttony
and greed the virtue of lust
is chastity the act of refraining from
sexual activity that may be considered
immoral
or in some cases from all sexual
activity
envy is a sin that ties closely together
with both greed
and lust it is a desire for what others
have
that leads to resentfulness and sadness
this can mean desiring someone's
possessions
achievements physical and personality
traits
or social status in some cases you may
not desire them
but instead wish that someone else did
not have them
envy is also separated into two
categories
malicious envy and benign envy
malicious envy is similar to jealousy
the negative emotion towards people you
perceive as
better off than yourself benign envy is
merely the recognition that someone is
better off or
in a better position than yourself this
type of envy is still negative
but it can be used in a positive way
such as the motivation to
emulate someone's success malicious envy
only leads down the path of hatred
isolation
and sorrow the only sin that weighs down
the soul more than envy is pride
the most famous example of envy at least
in the book of genesis
is kane murdering his brother abel
because he was jealous god favored his
brother's sacrifice over
his the virtue of envy
is kindness which involves compassion
and the satisfaction of one's situation
or position
sloth is a sin where we start to see the
separation from god
we mentioned earlier this isn't laziness
in terms of sitting around on the couch
all day
well actually it is but it also means a
spiritual laziness
the latin for sloth translates to mean
without
a care not caring about anything in your
current life
and even the afterlife whatever the
church perceived as
obligations and duties would be ignored
losing interest in hobbies friends work
and romance was seen to lead to sadness
and depression
all the sins so far have been something
you should not do
an act you should not commit but do
anyway
sloth however is the sin of omission
failing to do something you should you
may have heard of the phrases
the devil makes work for idle hands or
evil exists when good people fail to act
these are taken from a much older
sentiment relating to sloth
the virtue of sloth is diligence and a
persistent work ethic
the lack of stimulation relating to
one's mind and body
is still something many struggle to
overcome even today
the only sin left to cover now is wrath
the feeling of rage and anger that one
struggles to control
from wrath stems hatred and vengeance
that causes feuds which can last for
decades and even centuries
anger was not considered a sin unless it
was directed towards an
innocent person only then does it become
the sin
of wrath anger is normally divided into
three sub-sections
passive anger consists of defeatism
self-blame
and apathy this was seen as the path
that leads to
substance abuse and addiction aggressive
anger consists of bullying
hurtfulness and vengeance assertive
anger
involves calling out behavior you deem
as wrong blaming the individual
responsible for that behavior
and then punishing them the virtue of
wrath
is patience allowing people time to
change the way they behave
[Music]
hopefully you've enjoyed this video on
the seven deadly sins
i'm sure the comment section will be
full of anime references i don't
understand
and that's okay maybe it's something
i'll cover in the future
as always i've been your host mythology
and fiction explained
[Music]
hmm
you